foreign
yeah hello I I think it should be
audible now can you hear me
yeah I can hear you yeah that's great
how are you
oh yeah I'm just uh I'm just not doing
great because I got sick so I think I
will like spend most of the meeting the
background because most of the time I'm
sneezing and I don't want to broadcast
anything
sounds good hope you feel better soon
how's your dad
perfect
I'm just going to try and share my
screen can you let me know if you are
able to like read what's on there
sure
that looks good
okay
foreign
yeah usually we start like maybe a few
minutes after five after
yeah just a few minutes more until like
people
slowly down
foreign
yeah
Linda Linda right
Leandro yeah
that's are you from France
no I'm I'm Swiss
of Swiss okay
not far away
sorry
not far
uh where are you oh I'm in uh USA
okay yeah that's a little bit further I
mean you are not far from France that's
what I'm saying okay I'm not saying yeah
yeah that's true actually I'm going to
Paris next week it's only uh like three
three four hours away by train
I think Switzerland had like French or
German you know
different you know
region
yeah exactly in fact also Italian
oh really it's only a small piece but uh
yeah there's like an Italian part oh
it makes it clear makes you learn yeah
with almost Italian climate which is
nice so it's always a little bit warmer
there
nice nice
I saw you answered a lot of questions I
really appreciate it you know it's
helping us to understand
yeah uh
trying to do our best sometimes this
word is a little bit overwhelming I
really love the book uh from the
perspective of combining
Theory and the
coding
so you can see
how
this Theory
it's I mean it's not that theoretical so
it's not intimidating so
most people with some programming
experience can you know
it's really nice
glad to hear it yeah that was that was
the goal because we thought like most
people that want to actually use these
things they need to code so it makes
sense to explain it in code rather than
just interior because then you
essentially just their academics
yeah let me
yeah some books looks like a
mathematical book you know it's so much
Matrix manipulation
and I mean it sounds like intimidating
for some people
and but this I mean it's not necessary
that way right it's because everything
is already wrapped up in the library you
really don't need to know too much
of not that detail
indeed
cool
um let's see I think we we can get
started so welcome everyone to like the
the third session of the reading group
um today we're gonna do again like two
parts
um the first part focusing on the book
uh sidesh I agreed to give a quick
presentation on the anatomy chapter and
then we'll have some time to discuss
things that that are in there that can
be pretty much an open discussion
um and then at the end I'm gonna show a
little bit again like the open source
side
um so last time BB gave a nice
introduction how to contribute and how
to open APR on uh on an open source
project
um and I thought today it makes sense to
maybe get a little bit more deep dive
into like how you actually do it when
you have to run tests and what the CI
does of a repository
um to see like the whole entrant thing
cool uh I think with that I hand over to
you sadesh so you can give us an
introduction to Transformers and the
anatomy of Transformers
that sounds good uh
yeah if if anyone's not able to read
what's on my on the screen that I've
shared please let me know uh but hey my
name is Satish uh I'm a machine learning
engineer at Cash app
uh so yeah that's they played into this
uh so like today we will be talking
about the Transformer the third third
chapter which talks about the
Transformers uh Anatomy uh and we'll go
over the small the the building blocks
of what goes into the encoder and decode
a stack of Transformers and
simultaneously look at the code for it
uh which is largely just uh copied from
the book
so so the first component uh is the
scale dot product attention uh
in in the scale dot product attention we
have three inputs the query key and the
value vectors uh we compute a pairwise
DOT product for every pairs in the query
for the query and the key uh vectors uh
the scale part of it comes from scaling
uh this the attention scores uh which
are the which is basically the uh output
of this matrix multiplication by the
square root of t uh the original authors
of the paper basically uh explain uh why
you divide by square root of t uh and
it's under a limited assumption on the
vectors so uh basically you divide by
square root of T because you want to
make sure that the variance of the dot
product is in check
um
and uh you you can read read about that
in the original attention papers uh I'm
not totally convinced by that argument
because it makes a very limited
assumption on on the queries and the
keys Vector but anyways uh moving on to
the next part which is an optional mask
which we'll go over in the decoder part
but to start off with you can ignore
this
the output of the attention weights is
then passed through a soft Max to
normalize uh to normalize the the values
between 0 and 1 and those are then
multiplied by the value vectors uh which
gives a weighted uh which gives a linear
uh
uh which gives a weighted average of the
value vectors
so uh moving to the code uh like I said
there are three inputs the query key and
value and uh mask which we are ignoring
for now uh the shape of the query key
and the value vectors are of that size
uh the number of tokens in the sentence
and the embedding size
uh torch uh the batch matrix
multiplication in torch uh will then
take the query and then we transpose the
number of tokens and embedding size uh
dimensions of the key vectors and as a
result you get a tensor which is of
shape bat size by number of tokens by a
number of tokens which is what we want
uh next is the scaling part where you
divide by the square root of the
embedding Dimension and uh then you
normalize using softmax along the
dimension uh along the lower dimension
and uh this is just a statement to
basically check whether those attention
the soft Max the the attention weights
uh the sum of the attention rates is one
along the rows
and then you return uh another matrix
multiplication where
the representation for uh a value Vector
is a weighted uh is a weighted sum of
the other value vectors
so one question I had in my mind is why
not use the embeddings as queries keys
and values uh uh the embeddings
themselves as the queries keys and
values in the book uh in the in the
original Transformer architecture uh
there is a linear transformation that is
applied to the query key and the value
vectors and this is addressed in the
book as well but if you assume that the
norm of the embedding vectors is one uh
the maximum dot product that you can
achieve is one and that is achieved by
the same Vector so if you use the query
key and the value vectors as is so all
of them being the same you would have
once along the diagonal of the attention
scores Matrix and as a result which
would be the maximum value for every
along every row as well and as a result
softmax will assign the highest weight
to the same vector and as a result you
would be embedding the the value Vector
would be awaited some of all the value
vectors but the highest weight would
always be assigned to the uh
the vector representation of the word
itself and as a result you would not be
taking into consideration the context uh
which was which is the entire point of
using attention
uh
next to next is the Marty had attention
so uh
the MIT her attention we basically use
the same attention layer that we spoke
about now uh and and and replicated
three or four or five times uh in the
book in the original paper I believe
it's eight uh behind sorry
uh just quickly somebody in the chat
mentioned that if you could make the
font in the editor a little bit bigger
that might be helpful
uh is this good enough
yeah
okay
uh right so uh in uh my tea had
attention you you have multiple uh
attention heads uh and in order to uh
make sure that the output dimensional uh
the the embedding size of the output of
the MultiCare attention is the same as
the input each attention head will uh
each attention head will operate on a
smaller subset on a smaller dimension of
the uh of the original embedding
Dimensions so you need to make sure that
the poor head uh Dimension the embedding
Dimension is a multiple uh
of the number of heads is a integer
multiple of the number of heads
uh I thought this was a good point to
call out a Blog called The Illustrated
Transformer by jlmr I don't know if
people have heard about it but it's a
really great block and it was my first
introduction to to Transformers
and in the blog he uh he's a little his
section heading for multi-headed
attention is really dramatic he calls it
uh a beast with many heads so I just
passed through that past that text
prompt through
stable diffusion to generate this image
just a small aside
the next component of uh the the encoder
layer is the feed forward layer which is
a simple two layer feed forward Network
which uses the Galu non-linearity
and it is called a position wise feed
forward Network or 1D convolution
because the same uh same Matrix the same
uh the MLB is applied to each token in
the sentence
and
finally to put it all together there are
uh layer not there is layer knob and
skipped connections uh these both are
used utilized to basically Aid trading
and uh make training faster learn on uh
normalizes the uh normalizes the mean
and the variance to zero and one for
each uh for each token embedding and
Skip connections basically uh deals with
the vanishing gradient problem
uh so putting it all together uh the
Transformer encoder layer contains uh
multi-head attention uh two layer norms
and a feed forward Network and uh in the
forward pass to implement the skip
connections we add the output we add the
same input to the attention layer to the
output of the attention layer similarly
another skip connection where the output
of the layer not so this output is added
to the output of the feed forward
Network which is what this x is and
finally we return uh layer not the the
layer Norm the output of uh of this part
um so that's all that suddenly the
encoder of the Transformer the decoder
is largely the same with some minor uh
oh I skipped uh positional embedding so
um
so one part uh that I skipped over uh
that I don't have in code here is the
positional embeddings that are added to
each token in the Transformer uh since
the Transformer by its structure
does not take into consideration does
not have any sense of time since you're
just doing a linear combination uh since
you're just doing a linear combination
uh of the value vectors uh you need to
add some sense of the position of the
tokens when you pass that as an input to
the Transformer model that's where the
positional embeddings come into play uh
in the book The positional embeddings
are learned uh but in the original
Transformer paper uh they use this uh
cosine they use some combination of sine
and cosine waves to get a positional
embedding which is what is Illustrated
in this image where the y-axis is the
token position so each row corresponds
to uh the embedding that would be added
to the Token at position 0 position 1 so
on and so forth and the embedding
Dimension is the dimension is a vector
for each uh position embedded
and then moving on to mask
self-attention uh so similar to what we
saw uh similar to this dot product
retention we uh we just need to make a
minor modification to add a mask which
uh
is basically used to uh
remove the attention of uh so so it is
used in order to not take into
consideration certain part of a token
when Computing the embedding for it uh
in the decoder for uh in in the
Transformers decoder you need to mask
the tokens to the right of our word for
which you are making a prediction since
uh if you don't do that the transform
the decoder will basically learn to just
copy that output or copy that word copy
the next word in the sentence uh to the
output and that is not what we want
um so just do
uh
and and how uh so so let's maybe quickly
go over what the skilled our product
attention looks like
um so we get the attention scores as
usual we normalize them uh and then we
apply a mask uh so the
we uh the values which we want to mask
are set to negative Infinity uh negative
Infinity since once you apply a soft Max
to them those scores will become zero
and
just to quickly look at that
uh before the attention score so I am
printing the attention scores before
applying the mask
uh there are some random values after
applying the mask the off diagonal
elements in the upper triangular part of
the Matrix will be negative Infinity
and then after applying the soft Max the
attention weights in those in the same
position where there's negative Infinity
becomes zero
which is again very similar to the
encoder attention here that we saw
except for that it takes the key and the
value vectors from the from the output
of the encoder
and putting it all together
the the Transformer decoder layer uh
contains multi-head attention uh the
encoder decoder with mask multi-air
attention so we pass an argument for the
mask the encoded equal attention layer
uh the feed forward Network and three
layer Norms uh so one two and three and
uh yeah similar to how this was
implemented in the encoder we have some
skip connections uh
yeah and the encoder decode and the only
change in the function signature is that
you accept the key and the value vectors
from the encoder to compute the encoder
decoder attention
um and that's it does anyone have any
questions
you did some work uh by yourself
on top of the original
uh notebook from the book right
right I I haven't looked at the notebook
from the book uh but we encoder decoder
attention part was not uh implemented
I think
yeah I think we skipped that because the
chapter was already too long we were
told we we can't spend like half the
book on Theory
yeah
but I think your your implementation is
pretty clean
yeah I think also
um
in in on Discord somebody had a question
this week I think about like
how how the data is fed to to a decoder
like is is it fed sequentially and so on
and I think that plays into what you've
been showing with the mask attention
where you can see that you have to mask
um certain parts of the decoder inputs
so the decoder essentially gets during
training it gets like the the target
sequence as input but all all the words
the current word and the future words of
the sequence that the decoder has to
predict they're masked out so it doesn't
have access kind of like to the Future
and to the current token
that's that's the goal of the of the
Mask attention
test form
just for
architecture like gbt right like it's a
but for bird it's like you you do both
slang right
yeah
exactly
um so essentially they're like three
families of models there's the encoder
models like bird there's the decoder
models like gtt
and then there's the the the combination
of both which which is actually what the
original Transformer was which has an
encoder in decoder
and the masking of the the attention
happens both for encoder decoder models
and also for decoder only models like
Shifty
an example of an encoder decoder model
is for example T5
are there other questions
so
so
parallel processing
of the token like each batch
I remember the best size maximum if
512 something like that
uh the parallel processing that's a big
advantage over the
previous like uh RN and you know
architecture
I must see how it's implemented like
uh we do have some you know
implementation in the notebook like a
bmm no
um and I think that's nice I'm a Ponder
on this how
this parallel
thing is implemented like bmm it's kind
of a parallel
competition right I I I I Googled it a
little bit
um you know I you know I saw you know
the API
um I didn't spend enough time on it
maybe I think that's where the parallel
processing is from or maybe I don't know
so actual implementation is looking like
this or it's only in this book
no that's actually the implementation I
mean we we don't Implement like the the
exact Transformer
um implementation how it's done for
example in having phase because there's
a lot of like
code around it to make it work with the
Hub and so on but like the the gist of
it is like pretty much the same thing
um the the main reason why you can
parallelize
these that doesn't form much better than
let's say an lstm is for example if you
have an lstm what you need to do you
pass in like inputs sequentially and at
the very end you need for all the inputs
you need to kind of unroll the the lstn
each pass of the lstm you need to unroll
so if you're a very long dependent
um
let's say graph and you need to to back
propagate gradients through there and
you need to unroll it like essentially
at once and in in the Transformer right
like all the computations are very
independent from each other so you can
compute each head attention hat uh
independent of each other in the feed
forward the same thing right you can
apply it independently
then if you do things if you train a
model that's only
um like an encoder for example you can
you have even more
um Advantage because processing a whole
sequence takes only one pass through the
whole model because you can pass all the
inputs at the same time and you get all
the outputs and during training it's the
same thing for the decoder too so you
can pass like a lot of data and you
don't need to do like
feed the information back into itself so
that makes the the training and the
inference very efficient
um at the same time currently there is
like a limitation which is the context
size so attention is expensive in terms
of
um how many tokens you have uh see that
showed that you essentially get the
square Matrix right and the square
Matrix is number of tokens times number
of tokens
and so if you have a thousand tokens
then that gives you a matrix with a
million entries
and if you have like 10 000 tokens you
have a matrix with 100 million entries
so that doesn't scale very well and and
currently like one of the
biggest complaints people have or like
biggest requests let's put it that way
that people have is that can we have a
Transformer that has no more attention
because some people want to like for
example summarize a document that has
thousands of tokens and that's not super
straightforward and the Transformers
whereas like an architecture like an
lstn doesn't necessarily have that
constraint
uh Leandro I have a question yeah go for
it so you mentioned that
um models like these have small context
windows or so it's hard to kind of
expand to longer sequence sizes
uh could you do like a small fix where
you window
a model over a larger sequence and then
do something with the embeddings that
are produced by that window
or does that end up not being as helpful
yeah uh you can totally do things like
that
um I think there are some Transformer
architectures that kind of do something
like this I forgot which ones it is but
they they haven't
the architecture that have that
intrinsically I think they haven't
survived in a sense that I don't think
they they've been doing as well as other
models
um
I think Nicholas broad who works at
Hanging face he made like a small
library that does that for
classification very essentially you scan
through a document you make predictions
for each like chunk and then you pull
everything together and make an overall
prediction so that's totally possible
um there are also some models like long
former for example that have like a more
efficient
uh attention mechanism so you can they
have like larger context windows but
they're like notoriously hard to train
so sometimes you need to find like a
very specific set of hyper parameters
and then a Verge and so I think that has
been one of the main reasons why they
also haven't been like very widely
adapted yet
cool thanks for answering
sure
hello Leandro uh so I think it's a Max
right and as you mentioned because it's
a quadratic
and so you don't want to leave a huge
memory or computation footprint it's too
too expensive
so
that's one of the maybe shortcomings of
uh this Transformer I believe you know
researchers are working on it
um so is this a parameter you can tune
it like you you know you you don't want
to go above 12 but you can tune to to
make it smaller or the Transformer
architecture and make it a fix it's just
flat top you cannot change it
um so 512 is not like a universal number
I think 512 it was used for bird and a
few models around it
um tpt2 for example I think has a 1024
now near models they even have like 2
000 I think Bloom was trained with 2000
um context window
um and I think even some of them have
been trained with four thousand and
different kind of vanilla ones so that's
definitely something that you can
change but you need to usually to change
it during pre-training which is the
expensive part so once a model is
released like bird then you have to take
what you get you can always call smaller
but you can't easily go bigger
um one thing they used in for example
pre-training Bloom which is a model that
we've been training at hunting face in
like a open collaboration is a cool way
to use positional embeddings that's
called other by embeddings so sudash
showed that these positional encodings
which are essentially composed of like
sine and cosine overlaps
and one shortcoming is if you wanna
after pre-training if you want to go to
larger context Windows the model is
going to see like patterns that it has
never seen before so that's why it kind
of breaks down
but the the idea behind Alibi appendix
is that you have a mechanism that can
extrapolate so they did some experiments
where they went to like larger context
windows then they saw during
pre-training and you could see that the
model performs didn't degradate
so it's not I think 100 clear yet that
you gain a lot by doing that if the
model really can use it but at least the
model doesn't just completely fail if
you input something
um that has a larger context window
um but that doesn't solve the memory
issues when you go to larger sequences
so you you can still run out of memory
essentially that's what happens if you
pass in something that has too long
sequence then you don't have any memory
left so
with The Alibi embeddings you can still
do that so
it doesn't solve everything
um
another question about a traditional
embedding
I have been trying to understand it
I don't see a whole lot of explanation
about it I I did see the sign to sign
thing you mentioned
I would wonder how this could
I mean so so the reason for traditional
embedding it you wanna make sure
you do have something about position of
each token in the sequence
but if it's repeating like a cycle
science it's you could see some exact
the same value for maybe you know
because the sign because it's a circle I
mean Circle it's like periodic right
how could it
make it unique
uh so it's something I
I mean they didn't just go for like
vanilla cosine sign but they chose like
a pattern especially that doesn't repeat
so if you look how they do it they scale
it in a way such that each position has
like a unique pattern that you apply
and I think if you go back to like City
slides you can see like each position
looks slightly different than all the
others
which has the implementation for that
position embeddings in the chat as well
yeah now remember yeah it's uh we're a
complicated formula they have a they
raise something to the power of
something uh yeah yeah that makes a
unique now I remember
yeah also note that like not all models
use like these kind of positional
embeddings for example GPT used learned
embeddings so the the model has to learn
a pattern for itself that depends on on
the position
um and it varies a bit I don't think
like that many models use like the the
cosine sine pattern anymore a lot of
them use like Turned embeddings
learn positional embeddings or like
Alibi embeddings
um but I think it's a good entry point
to understand what what the idea is
cool any other questions
maybe this is off topic
uh
the multi modality
thing
if you want to elaborate a little bit I
mean it's off topic I'm sorry if you
feel you don't feel comfortable you know
you don't have to say anything
sure
um anything specific you want to know
about like multi-modality
like how you would hi Transformers I I
kind of uh
I don't know enough but uh
I think they're almost treating image or
video like they're treating that they're
making them talking
like
you are making language you know work
token
uh I mean it's it's mysterious to me now
because I have not spent enough time to
figure out
uh but it looks like they are trying to
make everything like almost like a large
language model am I right
yeah there has been some trending that I
think uh Vision has been one example
also like uh audio has been using
Transformers a lot because audio is
maybe more natural because it's kind of
like a sequence
and so you it makes sense to to
try to do it the same way and like wave
to rec2 for example is like a
Transformer that has like some
pre-processing before for audio
I think in Vision it's a little bit back
and forth uh I think Transformers were
very successful for language with like
that sequence approach so they try to
see can we do the same thing with images
so they essentially made small patches
of images and
is that kind of as like a token and that
seemed to be working very well
um but since then it's been a little bit
back and forth and likes people from the
computer vision Community came and say
like uh but actually if we do it better
we can do the same thing with commercial
convolutional neural network and I think
the the Cherry is still out but I think
at least it seems to be kind of
competitive
but it also requires like a lot of
pre-training
nice nice
sure
I think we still have like time for a
few more questions if
anybody wants to jump in
I got a weird question for you guys as
not not a data scientist
uh I do a lot of oh sent investigation
and
I sorry I'm like stuttering today I'm
trying to do all this research to find
the right tool and I can't so I'm
throwing it out to you guys is you know
I get confused about what is the
difference between machine learning NLP
AI I feel like they throw all of that
into one basket and it's not because
when I messed with NLP I think it was um
you know like machine learning like it's
it's it was neat because you're breaking
down like vocabulary and syntax and so
I'm trying to find something that can do
correlative models of data for ocean
investigations and I'm throwing it out
there to you guys like what can do that
in regards to NLP or machine learning
point me in the right direction please
uh like I'm ready to break a keyboard
here
laughs
okay can you explain what the ocean is I
don't know what that is ah sorry ah this
is so I'm so bad with that
um open source intelligence uh Gathering
uh for like ctfs and law enforcement and
I mean everybody uses even the criminals
are using it now to pick their targets
so and and I'm trying to find like when
you're doing thank you for doing that by
the way it was very you're a good
teacher if so if I was if I was doing an
investigation on something or due
diligence because investigation is a
legal term and I had all this data
there's nothing that exists even with
all the experts that can take that data
parse it in
and then make like a correlation so
let's say I was looking up you know you
look at somebody's social media right
you're gonna get emails usernames and
that's a manual process right now you
got to sit there and literally make
those connections yourself which is
stupid like we have ai and we we have
all these tools that like Dolly you know
Dolly can make pretty pictures like we
should be able to make those links
without having to do that with a pen and
paper
foreign
maybe I can start with like
um
your first question which is like what's
the difference between Ai and machine
learning and NLP
um and so
the the way I
so AI is like a pretty old term AI is
like I think originated like in the 50s
and it was like used for anything that
looks kind of like smart but it can even
be like a rule-based system so uh if if
you take for example deep blue which was
like a heuristic on how to play chess
that was kind of like considered AI
machine learning is like kind of a
subset of of of AI which is you use
statistical models that try to learn
from data that's not something
the the broad term of AI necessarily
needs to do if you have like a smart
rule that does something that doesn't
need to learn anything from data but
machine learning is the goal is to
somehow use data to learn something
automatically and then NLP is like kind
of like another dimension which is more
about what modality are you looking at
so that could be AIML
maybe a third term which is deep
learning is is like a subset of ml so AI
is the superset of ML and deep learning
is the subset of ml which is like mostly
about large neural networks
um in terms of of your question I think
like most of these models they're very
specific for a certain task
and I think what you're looking for is
like a combination of many tasks kind of
like a whole workflow that you're trying
to optimize and I don't think there are
currently many models that are very good
at that
um I know that companies for example
like palantir they're more like on that
domain trying to like extract a lot of
data and find like patterns in there but
I think they actually don't use that
much machine learning and use like a lot
of good like data engineering to achieve
that combined with a lot of rules well I
think in in terms of like data science
like I used to work as a data scientist
for quite a while and usually people
want to do something with fancy tools
but usually the way the right way to
look at it is like what's the right tool
to solve an issue and it can be a
combination of like rules with maybe
some machine learning models somewhere
but very rarely it makes sense to start
with with like fancy machine learning to
to solve like a very concrete use case
that answered right now I'm using the
autism tool it works very well you know
you see the pack but that being said
it's it's uh thank you for that it just
sucks that
you know because when people ask how do
you make these correlations I'm like ah
if you just threw a bag of M m's on the
floor I'm going to see a pattern so it's
one of those things that we got all
these tools and like you just you just
kind of solidified for me there is a
need but nobody's been able to do it and
you may have just answered it for me is
that sometimes when you over complicate
a process you make a complicated process
so it's kiss right keep it simple stupid
so there is no tool that actually exists
but what was the name of that company
can you put it in the chat the name of
that company you said that was working
on something yeah
thank you guys sorry I didn't mean to
take that you know down the next street
but
no worries
good
um I think that's a good point to make
the switch
um to to open source
um and I thought but I'm gonna show
today is
very briefly like what the things are
um that the steps are involved to
um
open a pull request on a repository but
more like on a very practical sense for
going from like
cloning a repository or making a four
cover repository then making some
changes making sure like all the tests
uh still work and then finally push
again make a poor request and it's
very similar to what Vivi showed but I
thought it makes sense to go a little
bit more in like the the details
um of of the steps involved and I think
for future sessions we we can do also a
little bit of voting and see like what
you're actually interested in or what do
you find like the most difficult parts
are in contributing to to like an open
source project
um so let me start by sharing my screen
and you see my screen now
yep we can see it cool can you see
evaluate
that that would be the right screen
yeah we can see
awesome
so
um instead of doing Transformers I
thought I do evaluate this week because
evaluate is a project I'm mostly very
calm so I'm a little bit more familiar
with it
um
and I wanted to show you like the full
all the steps involved to to open a PR
uh mainly like setting it up locally
which is like I think the one of the
main hurdles
um and so the first thing that you
usually do is you need to create a fork
because you're not allowed to to commit
anything to to the main repositories so
I'm just gonna create a fork
there
so now I have like the evaluate
repository
um
under my username and I can clone that
and so what I'm gonna do one second
I need to find
any terminal
a little bit bigger
so I have like a folder kit
but
and I'm going to make a directory
called
you know let me see
first delete it
so I'm gonna make a older word apps I'm
going into that folder and now I'm going
to clone
that uh
repository I have here
so now you see I've evaluate I'm going
to evaluate and now
probably one of the first things that
you usually need to do is you need to
install the things that evaluate
um uses and I'm usually using virtual
ends but you could also maybe use conda
or some other library to make virtual
environments that's usually a good idea
because if you install everything
globally you might break other projects
that you're working on and if you create
like a virtual environment you have like
a new self-contained thing and if you
install something in there then it's
only going to affect
um
that particular environment and not
everything that you have
so to install
um
what what evaluate needs is you usually
do like a pip install I mean some
repositories can be different you
usually can find some instructions in
the readme how to install things or if
there's like uh contribute guide usually
shows how you can install things
for example here
um and so if you want to install
everything that evaluate needs usually
what you do right if you want to install
evaluate it will just so evaluate
and that takes that takes the library
Forum from Pi Pi which is like the
released version but since we're going
to be working on it we're gonna do that
minus E
uh that means editable
and then we have a DOT which means you
reinstall whatever's in the folder that
we're currently in
and then you have that addition of Def
which is we don't not only going to
install everything that evaluate needs
but everything that evaluates needs for
development so when you release a
package you don't always release all the
the things you need to develop the
package for example you don't need unit
tests
um the depends of the unit tests the
dependency of your package
so if you do that that's going to
install a lot of things it's a very long
list of libraries
you can see it uses a lot of cash
because I did the same thing this
afternoon already but usually when you
do it the first time I see something
updated
um it needs to download a lot of
packages
now it's installing
yeah Andrew quick question I don't see
you or doing install evaluate but it's
installed so that minus E
it's doing the magic or what
yeah so the minus E and the dot if you
look
um at the at the folder that we're
currently in it has that setup Pi that's
from the evaluate repository and the
setup Pi is essentially the recipe to
install evaluate and if you do minus E
dot then that says install whatever is
folder you're currently in and then it
looks for that setup I think
okay okay so this is universal
I mean you can use it
in other
repository right to install other
package okay thank you yeah exactly
and do you want to do that because maybe
you want to test it and you want to test
against the local version not against
like the the last release or something
because you're going to make changes
right so you want to make sure
um if you import evaluate it's going to
import that folder that we're currently
in
so now we installed things I'm gonna
quickly uninstall tensorflow because I'm
on a Mac and that usually
breaks things with me you can make it
work with mini conduct but I rarely use
tensors mode so I'm gonna uninstall it
for now
but that's just a local thing for online
machine
um
I I use a vs code so I can open vs code
in that folder and
let me put that here you can also makes
that a bit bigger
and now you can
thank you
can see here weird
in the source code of evaluate usually
the source code is in a folder that's
either called Source or it has the same
name as the the package or like
combination of both
and so here you see like oh
um the code that's inside evaluate
and I don't know maybe we we just make a
stupid change
um let's see what do we want to do
maybe we we want to import another
package because we need that for
something so we're going to import for
example numpy at NP
and
you want to probably make a branch for
that and you can do all of that in in
um in in the terminal but I'm gonna show
you what I actually use because I'm very
bad at remembering commands so I usually
use a tool that's called git Kraken
you can see it here and it's like kind
of like a visual
um version of uh off git so it's a user
interface that you can use
and I go and I select evaluate and you
can see now
you can see um
the the git history that's essentially I
don't know if I can
oh yeah I can make that bigger as well
so that's the git history so you see all
the the previous comments that were made
and so what I now want to do is I don't
want to commit my my change to to to the
main branch I want to make a new branch
and maybe say
that's called uh numpy
I make that new Branch that's
essentially the same I think as git
checkout minus B
at Empire but I like the visual
and the other nice thing about git
Kraken is you can visually inspect all
the files that have changed so you can
see something changed in in loading
let me know if it's too small I can try
to zoom in a little bit more but
essentially you see the files that I've
changed and you see what has it changed
exactly and that's what I want to commit
so I stage that that's the same thing as
git add I add a commit message with this
numpy
uh numpy import
we commit
and now you can push
to
wherever we want
now usually before you do that you want
to do two extra steps
um and I'm gonna show you what you want
to do extra steps
um every time somebody commits something
to evaluate I'm going to go back to the
main repository to show you
everybody every time somebody creates a
pull request uh for example I don't know
we can look at Apple requests that I did
a couple of days ago
and every time we push something for
most of these repositories they have a
CI which is essentially tests that run
every time somebody adds something and
you can see for for evaluate it's
usually for tests it can be much more
um one of them is just building the
documentation one is code quality and
the other two are running the tests on
on Linux and windows
and so
one of the most common things that
happens is that the code check code
quality test fails and that just that's
just uh essentially a linter that just
makes sure that all the code in the
repository has like the same same format
for example you use single quotes or
double quotes for certain things and to
check call Quality just checks if all of
that is in order and a lot of time
people do what I just did they make the
fix make the changing code then push it
and then it fails and then you get
frustrated and probably I could also do
a count on my repository and I think 50
of the time that happens to me too that
I get too excited I just push and then
we figure out uh
uh you can actually see it on that PR I
pushed it failed and then you see a
follow-up comment which is fixed style
which is I forgot to to check the code
quality
and that's very annoying and sometimes
people get like frustrated with it and
maybe even even stopped working on it
because it's so annoying but actually
like fixing it is like very simple
um if it depends in in which
repositories you are a lot of
repositories use like different things
yeah for the hug and face ecosystems we
have a command for that and that's
essentially make style and make make
style and make quality and that runs the
the linter and you can see it actually
changed something
um where was it
so one it complains that numpy was
imported but never used and I think it
also changed some white spaces and if we
go back here we can see there's now an
additional change which is it changed
the ordering because there's some
definition of how the Imports should be
ordered and I've placed it in the wrong
place so that would be another candidate
for fixed Style
and
then you commit and push
now the second thing that can happen is
the core quality is fine but maybe you
broke something else and the test Suite
is trying to find if anything broke
um if you look in most open source
project there is a folder called tests
that has a lot of unit tests that make
sure all the functions do what they're
supposed to do and you can run the tests
locally also again depends a little bit
on the repository usually you find like
the exact instructions in the compute
contributing guide
um either you run I test
um
something like that against like the the
test folder
um most of the hugging face libraries
they also have a command for that where
you can just say make tests and then it
runs the tests
um with the the settings that are also
used
um in the CI on the Hub
so that usually takes like a few minutes
but then you can see it spins up
it actually runs the test in parallel so
you can see there are like a lot of
rotors that are starting and then it
runs through through all the tests that
are defined in here
um and that's much easier to debug than
every time pushing to the hub and then
waiting for for the tests to run
sometimes they can take a couple of
minutes uh but with that you can run
them locally and then you see see the
results
um so there's only one step missing so
let's say I now the test started you can
see they all pass which is good
um I'm gonna stop it
but um oh yeah let me maybe quickly show
at the end you usually you get like a
report that says
um how many tests passed and which one
failed and then you can look at them
specifically uh to see what happened
um and what do you do that maybe broke
something else in the library
um if we go back to
I want to go back to
um
my Repository
oops
oh yeah here you can see if you
now I'm in back in my repository and you
see either you can go to pull requests
and just say you want to open a pull
request and we'll show you the branches
or if you just push something it usually
shows you a message like that where you
say compare and pull request
and here you can select where you want
to add your change so either I can
go from my branch which is in my
repository and make a pull request to to
the main repository or I can also make
it to my own uh depends a little bit
what you want to do
um let's go back here
um and then what usually makes sense is
to write in detail
um
what what you did and what the pull
request is supposed to do because
somebody has to
um review that so the more descriptions
you add the more
um about your thinking behind like the
design of of your changes you add here
the easier it is for the reviewer to see
if the code that you're having is um
is is actually doing what it's supposed
to do and then
create the pull request and then wait
for for somebody
um to review it
um it helps if you allow edits by the
maintainers that means if you make a for
example pull request to evaluate I can
also make changes so I don't need to ask
you to make changes but I maybe if it's
like something easy and I can just fix
it I can also directly commit to your
branch
that's what that he does foreign
that's what I wanted to show
um I hope that helps a little bit more
in in terms of
contributing to open source let me
quickly
stop sharing because I don't see
anything
um
okay cool
are there any questions
yes yes oh Leandro i i i this is the
something you know I really think it's
really helpful I first I want to say you
know the testing I mean I saw the first
time you just did the code change and
you pushed me into the git uh I mean the
repository without testing locally
um I mean I I you know I guess there's
something in the repository it can
automatically
you know check your stuff that's why it
shows some warning
um then the second time you did some
local tests use the pi test right so I I
guess Pi test will only check maybe
grammar or you know syntax
uh it doesn't check the functionality
suppose you have done a really
complicated chain you know impacting the
functionality
are you gonna test locally or test in
the repository and if you need to test
low quality do you have the computing
power like in case you know you need a
GPU or whatever
yeah so the pie tests they actually do
test functionality they don't the the
make style and make quality data with
some like syntax things there's like uh
replace single quotes with double quotes
and so on but the pi test they they text
test functionality and they're the same
thing that runs remotely on the
repository so it's just a useful thing
to do locally because you can iterate
quicker you don't have to push to to a
repository
um to to see if it works you can do it
locally and you can even do it more fine
grained you can just if one test fails
you can just test that one again and
again until you fixed like what broke it
essentially
and in terms of computing usually these
tests they're not training models or
something like that they just test if
functionally the thing is still doing
the same thing and it as it was doing
before sometimes it does like a single
forward pass or a single back for a
person like a tiny tiny model but it
doesn't like take a 100 billion
parameter model and trains it or
something like that so these tests are
supposed to be very lightweight and they
should run like in a couple of minutes
even on on a local machine
I'm afraid we're kind of running out of
time so I wanna
say like a few organizational things and
you can if you have more questions about
the that last bit about open source you
can just post it in slack on slack and
Discord
I know I can try to answer your
questions
um on the organization side we're going
to do the same thing we did last week
we're going to make
um uh
um we're gonna ask which chapters you
want to see next and want to discuss
next and I think it would be really nice
like sidesh show today like giving like
a nice summary if someone uh would like
to do that that would be super cool
um as I said last time if you do that we
can either give you a book
um if you want one if you don't have one
um if you want like a hard copy Lewis
and I can sign it if that's something
you want
um or we can give you like a voucher on
from the angry face story so you can buy
like a hat or something
um that's one thing and the other thing
is like I think it would be cool to if
you are interested in contributing to
open source
um if you would try to do it there are a
lot of like good first issues and
Transformers or evaluate or a lot of
Open Source libraries that also doesn't
need to be and face ecosystem and you
can use like the Discord channel to to
look for help if you if you want to do
something if you maybe there's like a
few people who want to open a PR maybe
you want to work on it together if you
need some help or guidance you can ask
me or Lewis or some some other people
maybe opened uh some PRS before and we
can try to help you
so
that's one thing and
um one thing that we can also do we can
give the same kind of prizes to like the
the coolest PR or coolest uh thing you
did with the chapter so we're gonna do
it like for both if you want to do
something with the book maybe this this
week is not ideal because it was mostly
theoretical but maybe next week when we
train a model on something and you want
to build a cool demo or you want to
train a model on another data set or
something like that we can also do
something
um in that direction
foreign
so thanks a lot for showing up and
sticking around even though we went a
little bit over time
uh hope you have a nice day nice evening
and see you in two weeks
bye everyone bye thanks bye everyone
thanks thank you